[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in our good buddy steve
palazzolo the co-host of pro football
focus nfl podcast now that brady has
announced his retirement
how do you put his numbers in into
perspective here uh or quantify them
yeah i mean we our data at pff only goes
back to 2006 so we we missed the first
few seasons of brady's career but since
2006 you know we've graded every player
on every play in the nfl he's the number
one graded quarterback during that time
he's number one in our wins above
replacement metric by far that's the
same metric he was number one this past
year he we had him as the most valuable
player in the nfl and i was actually uh
i tweeted that out yesterday maybe a
little confusing the way i tweeted it
but he's the most valuable player you
know since the start of 2021 since the
start of 2020 since the start of 2018
the patrick mahomes era so i think
that's one way to quantify brady's
greatness no matter which year you pick
he's the most valuable player since that
point using our war metric um despite
having aaron rodgers and patrick mahomes
and drew brees and peyton manning and
all the other great quarterbacks that
have that have come and gone or are
still around in in the nfl right now so
but where do you factor in on naming him
mvp
yeah so for us it's it's it's it's
evaluating every single play right so we
go through each play and if brady makes
a great throw and it's dropped uh we're
gonna give him credit for that properly
right so it's isolating his play from
everyone else's and when you do that
back to 2006 he's he's our highest
graded he's our most valuable and then
in this particular season
where i think aaron rodgers probably
ends up winning the mvp we did have
brady
graded higher and more valuable because
a lot of those hidden plays went brady's
way where aaron rodgers had a little bit
more luck in those in you know in a few
other areas where brady didn't
particularly say like interceptions
brady's best year and worst year were
what
yeah it's tough to argue with 2007
as his best year i i honestly think 2016
was his best year you know so he's
coming off the deflategate deal as far
as throwing the football and pure pff
grade that was his best year from start
to finish they end up winning the super
bowl of course against the falcons worst
year uh 2013 2019 the two years where i
think if you look back at you know the
weapons and what was happening in new
england at that time it was also the two
worst supporting casts that that brady's
had but i think
2013 and 2019 are the two years that
stand out that clearly were not in line
with the rest of brady's career
what quarterbacks are close to him in
history
i mean just so just within the era i
think it was pretty clear it was brady
payton brees and rogers as that elite
tier but uh it is fascinating that
brady's even been able to you know
separate himself from that group of
course from a from a winning standpoint
you know he was always compared to joe
montana his idol there was a lot of
elements to their game that was similar
right the underdog mentality and always
finding a way to win and all the super
bowls and all that stuff so
you know i think i think brady clearly
established himself as the best
quarterback of all time but when you go
back and if you're even trying to debate
you're looking at a a peyton manning a
jill montana
and then within the era you know adding
rogers and brees to that i was also
looking back at 2019 i think he threw 24
touchdown passes for new england they
were moving on he was moving on like did
new england
do the right thing statistically
of moving on from brady looking at what
uh he did that season
yeah it's a tough one because i don't
think
their roster was just absolutely in
shambles they were coming off of three
horrible years drafting
uh you know there's qb stats are mostly
driven by the qb but very strongly
driven by the supporting cast as well by
how many you know good receivers you
have that get open and obviously brady
benefited a little bit from going to
tampa bay with great guys to throw to
um but it's interesting because our
numbers weren't as bad as say
the raw numbers right so a lot of qb
metrics had him 25th or 20th in the
league that particular year we had him
12th so we were saying look he's still
playing way better than the stats would
show so if you do put him into a better
situation he could perform and i don't
even think new england was equipped to
build that right situation for him in
2020 given you know their cap
limitations and you know the fact that
they hadn't drafted well in a few years
what how would you
quantify stafford's years in detroit
like how good a quarterback was he for a
bad team
yeah i always describe stafford as a guy
if you watch him
the right three games he looks
incredible i mean there's three games a
year right that he just looks
unbelievable
and and he's like he's streaky too he's
feeling it and you saw this a little bit
this year he's no look passes and he's
just making incredible plays but the
consistency was never there
my early prediction with him coming to
the rams is that i think mcveigh would
get the best out of him maybe have a
career year he's just getting to that
career year from a pff grade standpoint
he just just jumped over
his career mark over these last few
games but the production is through the
roof so i think stafford's always been a
good quarterback i've always thought of
him as the 10th or 11th best quarterback
of his era here which has been a pretty
good you know era of quarterbacks which
is a good quarterback right and again if
you put him in the right situation which
apparently he is right now with the rams
you can get a lot of production out of
him i'll ask you the same question i
asked carson palmer you can have matthew
stafford or joe
one game
i think
yeah so one game is interesting because
i think stafford's ceiling like that
high end is incredible i do think
borough's a better quarterback overall
right the youth factor and what he's
going to be going forward the one game
element of it though stafford can do
some special stuff right you also saw
him throw it to a safety there but burro
made those he had a couple bad decisions
in the fourth quarter as well so uh one
game it's closer but overall i'll take
joe burrow you know i don't want to
overuse the it factor thing
but
but but but there's an element to this
right going back to brady really quick
right there are still brady detractors
out there there's a few of them right
who are like oh he had a bad game here
he had a bad game there we just saw
patrick mahomes have a bad game right
there are bad games out there but what
made brady special is he always bounced
back whether within the game the next
game the next season he always bounced
back and i think burrow has elements of
that even when things aren't going great
you have that feeling joe burrow's going
to bounce back so give me borrow how
would you how did you grade jimmy
garoppolo this year
it was not his finest season um he
started off horrible he was good has he
had a finest season
yeah you know 2017 the six games that he
played with the 49ers after he came over
was probably the best stretch of play in
his career the funny thing about 2019
when they went to the super bowl we said
i said we had brady 12th that year
garoppolo was 13th in our grading that
year but he had that kyle shanahan
system so the stats were really good
plus the playmakers that they've had
there so garoppolo's been a top half of
the nfl quarterback and i think he was
say week seven through 18 or whatever
during the regular season but yeah this
playoff run was not good if it did
coincide with his thumb injury it did
look like he was having a trouble with
his accuracy maybe that was a factor but
garoppolo was a mid-tier at best type of
quarterback with high-end production in
part because of that system who were the
worst quarterbacks
grade wise this year
it was all the rookies you know zach
wilson really struggled and trevor
lawrence really struggled uh justin
fields came out of it a little bit
toward the end but they were
those were the bottom end guys baker
mayfield was was down there among the
the worst starting quarterbacks in the
nfl no matt jones
no not matt not all the rookies back was
good mac was uh mid-tier to high-end as
far as he didn't have as much on his
plate as far as what the patriots asked
him to do in most games but he was
accurate generally a good decision maker
mack jones by far the best of the
rookies but the other high-end rookies
trevor lawrence zack wilson those guys
struggled a bit
do you simulate the super bowl results
at pro football focus
um i i haven't we uh we do have an
analytics team that that works through
that i'm not sure what their uh what
their results are at the moment but we
do have stuff we've worked on
great to talk to you again steve thank
you for joining us
all right thanks dan steve palazzolo
co-host of pro football focus nfl
podcast yeah we thought it would be
interesting just to talk to him since
they grade every single play
and
that i don't think it was close for mvp
that brady was the best quarterback this
year